[موسيقى]
يعطيكم العافيه يا جماعه
كنت شغال على المايك شغال الامور تمام اول
مره بحكي والمايك بكون عادي
لا اصرخ
اتمنى كل حدا هون عم بيكون يومه تمام جميل
جدا واذا ما كان يومك جميل تتذكر انه هاي
مش نهايه العالم بكره اكيد اجمل انا اليوم
جاي احكي لكم شوي عن مسيرتي الشخصيه ولما
بحكي مسيرتي الشخصيه مش قصدي انا وين
اليوم قصدي عن الاشياء اللي تعلمتها في
طريقي لوين انا اليوم
كيف عقليتي تغيرت كيف نظرت الى الحياه
تغيرت وكيف هذا كله بيلعب دور فانت مين
بتكون
ليش هيك بصير معي
كبرت في بيت دائما مشحون بطاقه سلبيه
ابوي وامي كان دائما بينهم مشاكل
ما بتذكر شفتهم بيوم متصالحين مع بعض ما
عمري شفتهم بحضنوا بعض ما عمري شفتهم
حنونين على بعض
الطاقه السلبيه والصراخ ال 24 ساعه في
البيت خلاني ابلش احس انه بيتي زي السجن
واي فرصه بتجيني اكون برا هذا السجن بكون
انا مرتاح فيها مبسوط
بس المشكله انه كنت لما بطلع بشوف كيف
الحياه كان لازم تكون
اب يوصل اولاده على المدرسه
كيف الاب والام بروحوا ياخدوا اولادهم من
المدرسه وبيكونوا كلهم مبسوطين كيف الام
دايره بالها على البيت كله
كيف دايره بالها على الاولاد شو ياكلوا
معهم وكيف كان كل حدا هيك شكله مرتب
وشوي عشوي بلشت احس انه انا ما عندي هذا
الاشي
فصرت اكره اكون برا البيت اكثر ما بكره
اكون جوا البيت
ليش هيك عم بصير معي
وضعنا الماده ما كان افضل اشي في العالم
مرات يكون عنا اشي ناكله في البيت مرات ما
يكون عنا اشي ناكله في البيت
نروح ونرجع من المدرسه مشي
درجه الحراره اشي واربعين الشمس قيد رمح
مرات يزعل علينا التكاسي واذا احنا رايحين
في نفس الطريق اللي هم رايحين فيه كانوا
يوصلونا ومرات لا مرات اهالي اصحابنا
كانوا يوصلونا ومرات لا
بس كانت تيجي ايام يجي صاحب البيت يدق على
باب البيت ويطلب حدا كبير يحكي معه
عشان بده يطلب الاجار ووضعنا المادي ما
كان افضل شيء في العالم فنتاخر شوي في
الايجار كنا احنا نفتح باب البيت ونروح
النادي امي تيجي ويحكي معها ويبلش يصرخ
ونحن كلنا هيك صغار حواليهم بس صفنين في
الزلمه قاعد بصرخ على امي
كتير عاش الموقف هذا في راسي
اني احاول الاقي طريقه اتصرف فيها غير اني
اضل واقف هيك وصافن
ما قدرت مش قادر اتخيل لاني انا كنت صغير
ليش هيك بصير معي
اجيت عالدنيا بوثيقه سفر زي اللعنه عائق
في كل طريق انا ممكن اسلكه في حياتي اوراق
من الحكوميه تتاخر وانضطر نحكي مع فلان
يحكي مع فلان يحكي مع فلان بس عشان يمشي
لنا اوراقنا تمشي
ما كنت قادر اسافر اشوف جدي وستي الله
يرحمها
وانا ما عم بحكي عن الماديات انا عم بحكي
عن حريه اختيار السفر لو انا هسه قررت انه
انا بكره بدي اسافر اروح اشوف قرايبي برا
ما بقدر وانا ما اخترت هاي الوثيقه
انا اجيت على الدنيا وهي كانت موجوده
ليش هيك عم بصير معي
ليش هيك بصير معي ليش هيك بصير معي هاي هي
الجمله اللي كنت ارددها وانا صافن في
السما
هاي الجمله اللي كنت احكيها لحالي وانا
بتقلب على التخت مش عارف انام
هاي الجمله اللي كنت احكيها لما تصير اي
مشكله بغض النظر صغيره او كبيره اظل
احكيها هاي الجمله ليش هيك بصير معي
قد ما حكيت هاي الجمله صارت جزء مني كبرت
جواي
صرت اطلع على الحياه كلها بمنظور سلبي جدا
كانه ما بالبقلي اكون مبسوط ما بعرف اكون
مبسوط صرت اشوف انه سعاده كذب اشي لحظي
وبروح
بصير عيد ميلاد حدا احتفال بسيط هون ابصر
ايش هون كلهم قاعدين بيغنوا بس هيك عم
بعمل هيك
وعارف انه انا حارجع على البيت اللي انا
ما بحب اكون فيه عارف انه بكره حيكون زي
اليوم وعارف انه بعد بكره راح يكون زي
اليوم وكل الايام بشبهوا بعض فانا مربوط
فمشاعر الحزن فبروح على البيت وبسال حالي
ليش هيك بصير معي
لغايه ما في يوم سالت حالي سؤال جوهري جدا
ممكن هذا اهم سؤال اللي سالته في حياتي
وسالته لنفسي
ليش بسال حالي هذا السؤال اذا انا عارف
انه ما له اجابه
ادركت
المشكله مش في السؤال
ثغره السؤال كئيبه لو شلت عنصر السلبيه من
السؤال وحطيت عنصر ايجابي واحد بتتغير
النتيجه
تفتحت مداركي حسيت حالي طول عمري ميت جوع
وحطته قدامي وليمه
ادركت انه انا المشكله بس كان ناقصني شويه
وعي
على طول غيرت السؤال وحكيت
كيف استفيد من اللي صار معي
[تصفيق]
وسالت حالي كيف استفيد من اللي صار معي
رجعت شريط حياتي وصرت اتخيل في المواقف
بتخيلها شغاله قدامي وانا صافن فيها وواقف
بس لحالي طب انا هون كيف كان ممكن استفيد
عرفت انه قصه ابوي وامي علمتني كيف ما بدي
اصير
ومشاكلي انا ومرتي حنحل
مشاكلي انا ومرتي عم يحلها مع بعض واحنا
دايرين بالنا على الصغير
واكون حنون عليها واحط حالي مكانها تاركه
بيت اهلها وجاي تعيش معي حتشوفني 24 ساعه
حتشوفني حتى في منامها فكيف ما احتويها
كيف ما اكون سند لها اكثر من ما ابوها كان
ليها وهذا الحكي تعلمته بس من ابوي وامي
وثيقه السفر اللي ما كنت مبسوط فيها خلت
كل لحظه تهمني صرت اقدر كل شخص في حياتي
كاني لن اراه غدا كثير ناس طلعوا من حياتي
وسافروا للابد بس انا مبسوط لانه فعلنا كل
شيء معا
والدنيا هاي بتضحكني لانه وقتها ما كان في
فلوس وبحمد ربي انها كانت هيك لانه هسه
عندي قدره اقرا النفوس بعرف مين عن جد
منيح ومين بس منافق بعرف مع مين امشي ومع
مين اكبر بعرف مين ارافق صرت ماشي في
هالدنيا رافع راسي دائما واثق انه اللي
ربنا كاتبه دائما خير بغض النظر عن اللي
ظاهر صفي نيتك من جوا قبل ما تبلش
بالمظاهر
وتشوف كيف الدنيا هاي كلها حتبلش تشتغل
الك مش عليك
بس ما تنسى تصلي وما تنسى رضا والديك
وهيك انا اتحررت من عقليه الضحيه الفيكتم
من تاليتي عقليه الضحيه عندها قدره انها
تسلب منك كل انواع السعاده وتعبي بدالهم
حزن دائم
كل ما اسرعت انك تدرك انه عندك عقليه ضحيه
كل مكان احسن لك لازم نتصالح مع فكره ان
الدنيا هاي لا تخلو من المشاكل عشان هيك
بقول لك قف على ناصيه الحلم وقاتل قاتل
كلياتنا كل حدا في هاي الغرفه عنده مشاكله
الخاصه فيه بس اللي بيريحني انا شخصيا من
جوا انه انا عارف انه كل حدا مشكلته على
جده ممكن مشكلتك انا ما اتحملها ومشكلتي
ممكن انت ما تتحملها كل حدا مشكلته عجده
لا يكلف الله نفسا الا وسعها
يعني ما في غير هيك المشكله بتصير معك
عشان تقويك تجيك مشكله اكبر بتقويك تجيك
مشكله اكبر بتقويك قبل ما توصل لاقوى نسخه
من نفسك كيف بدك تعلم اولادك اذا انت ما
تعلمت
لا تسال حالك ليش هيك بصير معي
ادرك انه بصير معك هيك لسبب ممكن ما تفهمه
في وقتها هسه بس صدقا حتفهموا بعدين وكثير
منا صارت معنا مواقف صار معنا اشي
استغربنا ليش هيك صار بعدين بنفهم ليش هيك
صار وهي هيك الدنيا معارك لازم نتصالح مع
هاي الفكره المشاكل لن تنتهي نتعلم احنا
كيف نستفيد منها
وهذا بس المشاكل اللي بتصير معنا خارج عن
ارادتنا بعيد عن متناولنا بنكون قاعدين
وبتيجي المشكله لعنا لما تغيرت نظره الى
الحياه
ادركت انه انا صرت شاطر في كيف اتعامل مع
المشاكل اللي بتجيني
بس كمان لدرجه انه في مشاكل انا بخلقها
لنفسي وانا ما كنت عارف
يعني لو ترجع في الزمن خمس سنين لورا
بتقول لي تعال ابو الويس اطلع ستيج وبدك
تحكي قدام كل هذول لا لا لا ما بطلع احكي
شي غلط
تخيل يضحكوا علي طب اتخيل اكون كاتب ومجهز
كل اموري واطلع وما الاقي ولا حدا جاي ما
حدا يعبرني ليه اعمل في حالي هيك لا لا لا
التفكير في هذا النمط اللي انا كنت افكر
فيه
بيحد من امكانياتك انك تنمو في اماكن انت
مش متعود عليها السببها بالانجليزي
المعتقدات اللي بتحد
من ايش بيجي هذا الاشي من الخوف طب احنا
هل حدا فينا بيعرف شبوب الخوف
الخوف شيء مهم الخوف عباره عن منبه عقلك
وجسمك بيتفقوا انه يرموا لك اياه عشان انت
تدير بالك يعني انا لو واقف مثلا على حفه
جبل وعم بمشي جسمي وعقلي حيقولوا لي خاف
فانا اترجم هذا الخوف اني ادير بالي وين
عم بدعس عشان ما اوقع
طب ليه قبل ما اطلع على استيج هذا عقلي
وجسمي اعطوني نفس المنبه تبع الخطوط هذاك
مع انه هذاك بعرض حياتي للخطر
بس هاد ليه عم بيعطوني هذا المنبه معكم
اسلحه
مخي عم بحاول يحميني من اشياء ما صارت
ممكن تصير
بس هي ما صارت
وظيفه عقلي انه يحميني فهو اللي بيعمل
بيعمل اللي عليه
بس المشكله حاليا ما بعلمونا كيف ندرب
عقولنا
لازم عقلي يشتغل عندي مش انا اللي اشتغل
عند عقلي مش لازم عقلي يقول لي احنا خفنا
ما بزبط نعمل هيك لا
الخوف منبه صح الواحد يخاف بس مش صح
الواحد يفكر بخوف
لانه اول ما يفكر بالخوف بلش يحد من
امكانياته
والافكار السلبيه اللي بتجينا لازم
كلياتنا ندرك انه هاي المفروض تكون افكار
عابره فقط
انتروسكوتس افكار تطرفيه افكار تدخليه
بتعرفوا ليش هيك اسمهم
لانهم بتدخلوا فيما لا يعنيهم
تكون انت بدك تعمل اشي في حياتك تجيك هاي
الفكره هي لازم تكون فكره وتضلها رايحه
عابره
بس احنا بنشبك عواطفنا مع هاي الفكره تيجي
الفكره بتخوفنا
وبعدين خوفتنا حركتنا عاطفيه مدام حركتنا
عاطفيه نحن لبدنا قعدنا وصرنا بس نفكر
ونستقبل افكار زيها يضلهم يخوفونا لانه
نحن ما بندرب عقولنا
هاي هي النقطه احنا طول اليوم قاعدين على
التلفونات بنقلب بنقلب بنقلب احنا بنحرق
مستقبلات الدوبامين في عقولنا بنحس حالنا
انه احنا عم ننجز واحنا ما بننجز ولما
بنصحى حالنا انه احنا ما بننجزم بنزعل
ولما بنزعل بنخاف ولما بنخاف بنهد من
حالنا
كله مربوط في بعضه من عقليه الضحيه
للمعتقدات اللي بتحد للافكار السلبيه
نحن ما بنقرا ولانه ما بنقرا ما بنعرفه
لانه ما بنعرف بنخاف كل اشي حيودينا لانه
نرجع نخاف ونحب من حالنا معدلات
الكورتيزول عنا كلياتنا مرتفعه فوق الخيال
طب ما هو معدل الكورتيزول هذا جزء من
وظائفه انه يخلي جسمك يعرف يتعامل مع
الستريس مع الضغط ضغط نفسي ضغط جسدي كل
انواع الضغط طب احنا هذا الحكي ما بنعرفه
بنهد من حالنا
ارجوكم اتذكروا ان الانترنت مش مكان فقط
الواحد يفوت يستهلك فيه متعه او يضيع عليه
وقت الانترنت مكان كتير كبير ممكن تعمل
عليه ايش ما بدك ومنهم انك تتعلم فخلونا
دائما عم نتعلم دائما عم نسال دائما عم
بنجاوب ودائما دائما دائما نفكر بايجابيه
والله انا يعني ما بقدر احكي لكم عن موضوع
الايجابيه كفايه بس هحاول
احنا تعلمنا او ما بعرف كيف صرنا هيك صرنا
نحكي عن حالنا بسخريه ممكن عشان نضحك ناس
ممكن عشان نفرجي الناس انه احنا متصالحين
مع جزء معين فينا بس بنحكي عن حالنا
بسخريه كثير منا سمع كلمه يا زلمه انا تبع
حب هاي الجمله مصيبه هاي هاي بحد ذاتها
مصيبه لانه وظيفه عقلي وظيفه عقلك وعقلك
عقولنا كلها وظيفتها انه نحن صح اذا انا
صحيت الصبح وقلت يا بييه اليوم حيكون احلى
يوم في العالم وظيفه عقلي انه انا صح
وفي المقابل لو صحيت اليوم حكيت يا الله
والله طايق اشوف حدا وظيفه عقلي يثبت لي
انه انا صح
فانا بختار وين يومي حيكون لازم اضلني
افكر بايجابيه تفائلوا بالخير تجدوه
فكر بايجابيه نقرا اكثر نتعلم اكثر نضلنا
ايجابيين والحياه حتصير زي ما بدنا وانا
بوعدكم انا وسام قطب
شكرا شكرا
[موسيقى]